[Music]
[Applause]
reggie miller hall of famer turner's
sports analyst he's on the call for
tnt's coverage of the mavs and the sun
series game five coming up tonight in
phoenix at 10 eastern how are you reg
i'm much better than you my friend
how are you feeling
well wishes out to you and i'm sure your
family as well because if you get it
most likely they may get it so i hope uh
the theodore family is doing well
well you remember jordan when he was in
utah and he had the flu game i mean yeah
yeah that's what
that's what this is about only it's five
times worse i mean
i'm okay well let me ask a question who
is the pippin who's holding you up like
who who's carrying you to the bench
every time out oh you're pippin i don't
think any i have anybody that strong
nobody
i would have marvin but he's got small
hands and he might drop me and i i just
i i worry about that
[Laughter]
well well wishes i hope you get uh 100
well soon my friend hey reg do they
measure hand size in the nba
like at the combine
they didn't when i came out in 87
obviously they do a lot of things back
in 1987. but they do now
they do now and i do believe
kawhi leonard
still
registered to date has the biggest hands
i may be wrong on this but
if he doesn't have the biggest he's one
of the top three in terms of hand size
yes they do measure wasn't this a big
deal for shaq that his hands were too
big you know that was always the well
his hands are so big that's why he can't
shoot free throws i'm like
i don't know kareem could shoot free
throws and last i looked he seemed
pretty big as well so i don't can you
have too big of hands in the nba
well i don't think so i mean mj has huge
hands and he was a pretty good free
throw shooter shooter scorer so yeah i
think shaq did okay in his career right
having big hands and
you know
like he would always tell us
while we were playing them
cause i would be reg uh uh i'm gonna
make the ones that matter the most
and sure enough he made the ones that
mattered the most against us did you see
where rudy gobert said he would lock up
shaq if shaq was playing against rudy
gobert
what's rudy talking about
it it's almost laughable because i i'm
trying to think of players in the 90s
that had somewhat of rudy gobert's
size at seven feet slender frame
um david robinson comes to mind yeah um
and
i think shaq kind of ate him up at times
but
it's almost laughable it it's hard to
say because look shaq's not playing and
rudy's in the league right now
but
there was no answer for shaquille o'neal
and i know you know he's a co-worker
people think well of course you're going
to say nice things about him i couldn't
stand the dudes because the dude denied
me a ring
so
i'm not saying this because he's a
co-worker i'm saying
we personally had no answer for him we
had rick smith
antonio davis
sam perkins we we threw everything at
shaq
and we could not stop him
and uh asked jason kidd the same thing
asked to kimmy mutumbo in philadelphia
the same we there was no answer for
shaquille o'neal so rudy i love you
you're a what three or four time
defensive player of the year that's
great
but trust me dude y'all wanna have zero
answer for
shakalicious down low okay how would
shaq would shaq be better now or worse
now
it's funny you say that i think worse
i i don't think he would
he would obviously still be dominant but
because the rules are now
i mean he would have to have someone of
a face up game which he doesn't have you
know who i would love to see shot go
against would be joel embiid or yokit
the
current and back-to-back mvp
i think yoga would give him more of a
problem than rudy gobert
how so because rick rick did
early rick smith when shaq was younger
and in orlando
rick smith gave him a lot of problem
because he could face him up and he
could score over either shoulder shaq
admits that
now when shaq
became with the lakers and was the most
dominant player uh in the game
he owned rick but i would love to see
shaq versus yokage and his skill set
that would be a little bit more fair
of a comparison
yeah
i'm i'm curious about that as well like
you jokic people have problems it feels
like now because we're seeing what
happens in the postseason luke is
playing well for his team embiid comes
back we see his value
you know the joker won this based off
the regular season
my problem is
yeah but reg the longer we wait to hand
out the award it feels like that person
is open to more criticism
joker can't play they balan you know
they were bounced early by golden state
we know that
but this is what they did during the
regular season if they give the award
right after the end of the regular
season then i don't think we have this
argument or you know
a further discussion on this and i think
it's unfair to joker you don't want to
give it to him okay fine if you think
he's just a statistical anomaly and you
know the nerds love this and analytics
then fine
but
he did what he did during the regular
season that's what this is based upon
100 agree with you
drop the mic on all that and
i i think the league is somewhat
dropping the ball by extending these
regular season awards
as the playoffs kind of you know tredge
on i think they just need to drop all
the awards the first day or the second
day of the playoffs and let them be
because it's not fair to the joker and
let me be clear here
him winning back-to-back mvps people
need to understand it's a regular
season award not the playoffs that's why
we have a finals mvp
for what guys do somewhat during the
playoffs but more importantly what they
do if they're lucky enough to get to the
nba finals that's the mvp all players
want because at number one you won the
championship and you were the best
player in that series so it's not fair
to the joker
he had an unbelievable uh season along
with joe uh
um joelle embiid you it was either or in
my opinion they both deserved it they
both played unbelievable but people need
to understand it's a regular season
award and that's why he got it reggie's
on the call for tnt's coverage mavericks
sons game five tonight in phoenix at 10
eastern
how big of a deal will the chris paul
uh family
fan interaction be with tonight's
broadcast
oh none i i think uh
chris said his piece and i'm
the
uh
dallas mavericks and their security
staff have addressed the situation i
don't think that will have any lingering
effect here on gate five
what the suns need to have
more concern on is
getting out to the dallas maverick
shooters
it this series is so simple if you look
at games one and two
monty williams and the sun said luca
beat us
45 in game one 35 in game two but they
shut down all the others brunson
dinwiddie
finney smith
maxi cleaver to a certain degree
and they won going away when it shifted
to dallas
lucas usage rage came down he was still
good he wasn't great but everyone else
the others their usage rate went up guys
started to make shot and that's what
happens normally when you're in your
home
court
you know surroundings so they
if you're the sons you're more concerned
about now the others have gotten going
what happens if luca has one of those
luca games on the road and those guys
continue to make shots
you could very well see the mavericks
coming in here in the pivotal game five
when it's 2-2
they could win this game if those guys
continue to make those threes like
they're doing
i was wondering about the fans fans
interaction feels like they're a little
bit more emboldened than they've ever
been it feels like we see it more
there's cell phone cameras here compare
fans fan interaction with players when
you were playing as opposed to what
you know we're seeing right now almost
on a nightly basis
well you're just seeing it now because
what you just mentioned cell phone
videos it really wasn't that
when i was going through
look the fans say some crazy
stuff i'm not gonna lie they do
and could you get a fan kicked out reg
could did you ever back in the day could
you say i want that fan removed like
lebron did to that couple uh earlier
this year
you could um
it will depend on the situation lebron
chris paul and all players russell
westbrook has done it a few times you
know the incident he had in utah i
believe it was yeah
look fans do cross the line of some of
the things they say and yes you can have
fans reboot it helps if the official is
near and can hear some of this stuff
um but when it turns towards a player's
family
and i'm on team chris paul on this
because if someone would have put hands
on my mama bear with my kids watching
that forget the game
i'm jumping the rope tube and heading up
in the stands and i know players always
get you know the black eye when they
react we're not robots right because
good and well you wouldn't say this to
me if i'm walking down the street
but you're going to say this in this
controlled environment
especially to his wife so i understand
the frustration that cp3 is going
through
um i would have liked to have seen more
sun security with the family
because you are walking into a hostile
environment but that gives that still
doesn't give any right for someone to
put hands on you
joking drunk or not do not put your
hands on anyone else especially a female
you just don't go there and you knew
that his kids are right there with her
there's no excuse for that i'm glad they
addressed it
but
i would have a hard time not going into
the stands chasing the dude as well
that's just my thinking
i don't know how athletes
stop themselves from going after
somebody because you can hear it
and you can act like you don't hear it
but if you if you cross the line it's
going to cost you a lot
but dan let me just say this
i've heard a lot of vile things in my
career
directed towards me i get that that's
part of the beast i somewhat sign i did
sign up for it being in a professional
athlete in a professional setting i get
that the problem i have is if you're
going to direct that to a family member
of mine who has come to support me
and you direct that
and then it gets physical that's the
problem i have
i can take all the vile comments and the
vulgar comments i just feel that i have
broad shoulders and i can shut you up
with my play and if i don't you'll see
me another day to try and do that but
when it turns physical
that's the problem i have where
i just let people know we are not robots
because
i wouldn't do that to you or your family
members so don't do that to my family
members and think it's okay
well said
bucks celtics um we got a series
these two teams don't like each other
and and i i mean boston could be up
three games to one feels like they've
been the better team here in milwaukee
without chris middleton uh al horford al
horford's your age reg
[Laughter]
don't say that the man is 34 years old
okay feels like he's 54 years old and
some of the games that he's played this
year
but isn't that isn't this the great
thing about the playoffs when guys out
of nowhere
al horford dorian finney smith makes
goes eight for 12
from threes for dallas
that's the beauty of the playoffs who of
your others who can step up at the right
moment at the right time
and if you're
milwaukee you're starting to think
okay i know middleton is not coming back
for the rest of the series
does giannis have enough in the tank
going against
uh
grant williams al horford
jayson tatum and jalen brown these are
four guys that they it's like a
revolving door that's having to guard
giannis and it kind of looks like it is
he wearing down a little bit
without his robin next to him in terms
of chris middleton being that second guy
to take the load off of him for scoring
yeah you start to look at this and you
go okay
milwaukee
should be the better team but that's if
they're fully assembled i i necessarily
wouldn't say that because
the celtics let's not forget
second best record second best record in
the east and have the best defense
uh since january 1st so it
i'm not surprised at what we're seeing
um case in point look what they did to
kevin durant and kyrie irving in the
first round so we shouldn't be surprised
at how they are limiting
um
the bucks and giannis
um i just think
boston has something special brewing
but you cannot forget and i'll go back
to
what milwaukee did
after losing those first two to phoenix
last year in the nba playoffs and
rattling off four straight and how
giannis was fantastic especially in
those last two ball games i never want
to put anything past him because he is
that special of a guy who can
on given nights
can carry you he hasn't shot the ball
great so you have to assume he's due to
have one of those games where he just
goes crazy but i i think the series is
going seven it's
it's it's good it's fun to watch
i i don't want who is the most valuable
player
i want who is the best player in the nba
okay i'm gonna approach it towards this
if i was on the floor in my prime who do
i think i would have a better shot at
winning
right now
wow
i like i really love joel embiid i just
think he put so much pressure
at both ends of the floor
uh i like joel embiid see you you would
be
you would be better with the joker
probably with the joker because of his
passing oh yes yes yes yeah um i mean i
would take
giannis i think is the best player um
i i i just think offensively and
defensively he's and i he it feels like
he's
consistent uh
embiid is great
but if you said
you know going out there
who could help you win a championship i
would definitely say joker would
over the other two but i i think
freaking i think john is good giannis
could too and i think
i think lebron you know we keep sliding
lebron too
i mean i know he's 37 and all but
not the best player
not the best player he's not the best
player in the game but you can win you
can win with him yeah but could you
you could win with
could you win with luca
he's making some dudes that were at
walmart a year ago look pretty good
okay
he's making some dudes that were like on
the chopping block look like all-stars
well that's why
but i that's when people say well look
at what joker did with his supporting
cast i said look what luke is doing with
his supporting cast there like if you
really want to give credit to somebody
luca could emerge as the most valuable
player
by the end of these play if they knock
off phoenix and he goes to the western
conference finals with that group
then
you know now we're talking about oh what
you did with
the supporting cast and luke is putting
up unbelievable numbers every single
night and he's doing it in the
postseason
davis for tons maxi cleava
dorian finney smith and people are like
uh who what dwight powell
think about some of the names i'm
mentioning here and luca has made them
look like he's getting them paid right
now he's getting them paid yeah brunson
brunson's going to get paid uh
jalen brunson is definitely going to get
paid
have fun tonight reg
before i go you could also make the case
for joel embiid look at the first two
games without him in miami yeah
they look terrible
he comes back with the mask the series
is tied to two heading back to south
beach so we can make the case for joel
embiid as well the over under for james
harden tonight is 20 and a half
what do you have
or james harden yeah jane
i
i think stella
has found her groove i think game four
where he went crazy i think he's figured
out
i am a former mvp
i have been running up to mvp a couple
of seasons wait he just didn't get in
shape overnight reg come on
i'm taking the i'm taking the over all
right i think he's i think he figures it
out
all right
he's still not in shape
you're not you're in better shape you
haven't played in how many years
you're in better shape than james harden
is right
oh no i am not don't try it don't try to
bait me you are in better shape
james james don't handle your business
just stay away from the cuban food just
stay away from the cuban food and he'll
be all right if you guys run away from
crime if you were on a tandem bike you
would be doing all the pedaling reg
hey james
hey you're not going to break us up
thank you thank you
reg love you theodore get well soon my
friend
reggie will be on the call tonight it's
game five in phoenix that's at 10
eastern mavericks and the suns